but also brandon i want to talk to you
though okay uh
you you walked away you voted for trump
yes will you still vote for trump hmm
well uh i want to you know keep my
options open for whatever uh
i'm a big ron de santos
so
let's pull this up real quick we have
this from timcast.com trump and desantis
are now tied as 2024 front-runners on
predict it so predict it of course is
you know people can
buy shares essentially who they think
they're going to win well what do you
think first
you want to keep your your options open
you said well all i mean is that i want
to
he has to announce i mean that's the
whole thing is he going to announce or
not i mean i think that most people
think that he is definitely um
so i mean if he announces and he's he if
he announces
i don't think that anyone can take him
nor do i think that ron desantis will
even run if he announces so in that
scenario uh definitely i mean would you
vote for him if he if he runs yes
would you vote for him even if he shot
someone on fifth avenue
that's the real question uh probably
yeah honestly
i mean got him
but
you know i think that um
a lot of people are very excited about
desantis right now uh i definitely think
i don't like a lot of what i'm seeing on
the trump side in terms of the devotion
like i get it when he was in office i
even get it when he was running because
he was so different
uh i you know i think that he uh he got
it he understood the concerns of the
american people at a time then people
feel like america is being sold out and
they needed a hero
and i think that he was that hero you
know for for a really long time
but at this point
um because people i think are so
desperate about how the 2020 election
went and how things currently are in
this country
there are factions within the trump
community that are becoming cultish
and you're not allowed
you're not allowed to criticize him
you're not allowed to ask questions
you're not allowed to express a
disfavorable opinion about anything that
he does and then okay now we are
becoming the thing that the left has set
if that's what it's going to be i don't
want to be i will not be a part of a
cult so if i'm not allowed to criticize
trump or if i'm not allowed to question
decisions that he makes
like endorsing dr oz or
okay yeah but if i'm not allowed to say
that then then i am out because i'm not
gonna be a part of that culture no but
you can still vote for trump you know
like yeah i will i will but there's a
difference between going in and voting
for him and being really outspoken and
endorsing and you know i
i i think that i influenced a lot of
people to come around to him in 2020.
for sure you know the the the hardcore
trump supporters really do not like me
because i won't support trump's
narrative on the election fraud stuff
because i just think it's
look
i think the issue is you need to discuss
what happened in 2020
in a
methodical way
the problem is a lot of people put push
these extreme stories about you know
servers in germany and watermarked
ballots i look forward to sitting down
with with former president trump because
we're
we're planning on you know getting an
interview with him hopefully no
guarantees it's i'd be honored it'd be
an honor and a privilege um but i would
like to ask him mr president did you
watermark any ballots and when he says
no i'll be like okay
see this is the issue that youtube is
banning people for they're banning
people for those wild stories about
secret behind-the-scenes missions and
what needs to be expressed is that time
magazine ran an article saying the
shadow campaign to fortify the election
or to save the election and you talk
about how rules were changed about
election laws about universal mail and
voting and the process that took over a
year that resulted in a defeat
so donald trump can come out and say all
these things but if he says it in a way
where he's talking about
those things
then you've got no problem
the issue is there's a lot of people who
want to believe the craziest scenarios
because
they can't admit that people were
willing to vote for for joe biden
destroying this country because they
hated trump so much and i think
i think that's what happened i think
there's there's obvious bs that we saw
we saw videos there's uh bill barr said
there was fraud but just not enough of
it i think we saw unconstitutional
voting rules this is this literally
happened in pennsylvania where a judge
ruled the voting law change was
unconstitutional but only after the fact
right those things that happened okay
like that would you focus on that stuff
and you stay away from the more
conspiratorial stuff now my point here
most people are referring to that stuff
and not the weird conspiracy stuff right
youtube will conflate all of it and the
media will conflate all of it so that
when you're trying to talk to people
they don't understand what you're trying
to say yeah it's like a psychological
surgery where if you make a mistake the
patient will die and that's how the
censors are treating this conversation
you have to be extremely
uh i guess accurate and um i don't know
there's other words for it but direct
and focused and intentional when you're
communicating about this election fraud
in general i mean it's a huge
conversation it's important conversation
but
the whole situation the whole question
around the election i guess i'll put it
that way
is i think
one of the most prime examples of
what has caused trump people to be trump
people in the first place i mean this
this enormous sect of people in this
country who just get rolled over they're
not listened to they're not respected
nobody people treat them like they don't
exist and we know that at minimum at
minimum he got 74 million people to come
out and vote for him which is enormous
that's huge
but those 74 million people at minimum
are treated like their concerns don't
matter and i have to say look if it was
literally the other way around
and uh
there were 74 million biden voters who
were outraged and thought the election
was fixed i'd say let's put their mind
at ease let's settle this i don't that's
that's what happened with hillary
clinton because i don't want this device
and i just want to mention it's not just
that they're told that their concerns
don't matter they are told that they
have the most abhorrent racist sexist
bigoted concerns you could ever possibly
have they're basically neo-nazis they're
horrible people who should be excluded
from public life if they ever have the
audacity to voice any of their actual
opinions about anything but i guess my
point is that
this was never
this was never worked through this was
never settled at all yeah and in fact
even the people on the left who
who i think in a very sort of elitist
and mocking way address the people who
have concerns on the right you know they
say um
there there's no substantial evidence
that this happened this has all been
discredited this has all been
discredited by who yeah and when no i
mean really
and i don't know people who would never
have wanted it to be true
why would you not want to validate and
verify that you won
that doesn't make any sense to me
rub it in our faces
rub it in i mean i just can assume and
it's i assume fear they're afraid that
if they do the right thing that they'll
end up losing and then that will be the
end of the world i don't know about it
that's a drastic firebase i'm wondering
where the arizona audit stuff went a lot
of the stuff that came out people were
like tim why don't you talk about the
arizona stuff i'm like we did like five
times like we had like multiple guests
on who went through the data we actually
sat down with them and then when the
stuff from arizona comes out it's the
same stuff we already talked about and i
was like what am i supposed to say to
this and then they disappeared
and i'm just like they were checking for
watermarks and stuff and i was like guys
i people want to believe
that the world is something more than it
is i got news for everybody the world is
boring there is no cabal you have people
like bill gates for sure but i've i've
been to uh i've been at davos not for
the actual world economic forum but i
was in the peripheral events where
people were setting up
i've i've met with powerful politicians
and ultra wealthy individuals and
they're clueless at the time they're
just powerful so when they have a whim
they do something crazy
i don't think that there is a you know
beneath the streets of dc hooded figures
our meeting and having these
conversations i know i'm being a little
facetious i don't i don't think that
they secretly meet together i think it's
overt i think you know they're meeting
at bilderberg you know they're meeting
at the world economic forum they
broadcast what they're saying from the
world economic forum to the world
that you know when it comes to what
happens with trump they wrote a news
article in time magazine about what they
did
and it was a lot of new voter rules it
was a lot of get out the vote stuff it
was nefarious behind the scenes big tech
billionaires and things like that and
it's it's all out in the open it's all
known what you know how how they how
they did this to trump to fortify the
elections but what's not out in the open
or known is what the dominion servers
tallied it's proprietary and they did it
behind the scenes and then told us what
it said and we just had to take them at
face value if we're going to fortify
this election for real we need some sort
of like third gap where our votes are
put on a blockchain and they can be
observed ian in about dominion
you're right
thank you tim good to see you again yeah
we don't know a proprietary voting
machine we don't know what's on it so i
can certainly see if people are upset
about that my response immediately is
open source publicly available code for
for our voting systems like how could a
private company control that that's
insane to me i'm not i'm not saying
anything nefarious happened i just don't
know because it's private right that's
interesting you guys just brought this
up because i was actually just about to
say it wasn't even for me some of the
more um
i don't know what words to use because i
don't want to offend anybody but like
you know kind of more on the fringe
theories about what went wrong in the
election the watermarks that you know
and and some people
really went pretty far with the dominion
stuff
in my opinion that was never it for me
you know i wasn't really subscribing to
or that to me was not like the key thing
to me it was the stuff like
governors changing voting laws and
manipulating the pandemic which is not
the process you're go you're supposed to
go through to change voting laws it's
supposed to go through the legislatures
and then they had things like well we're
going to extend you know people can mail
them in and we're going to accept the
mail-in until this date well they were
counting ballots that came in three days
or more after the the date and then a
lot of people said they came in they
didn't have signatures that's not okay
the signatures didn't match or weren't
recognizable that's not okay so my
question was only
how many of those ballots did you count
that didn't have signatures or the
signature signatures didn't match or
they came in after the due date that or
you know
this is the issue for me too right um we
saw a lot of that i think the universal
mail-in voting stuff gives a massive
advantage to democrats we saw
republicans in georgia and pennsylvania
basically aligned with the democrat
proposals on change to voter rules in in
pennsylvania it was republicans who
actually did a deal with democrats to
create universal mail in voting despite
what the laws actually permitted in the
constitution and so i think the issue is
those are really great points
i think we need to have an investigation
a conversation around that
uh the problem is the media will exploit
the fringe of the conspiracies to
discredit any legitimate questions
around what you know concerns we have in
the in the election well but you know
another question i have too is
why don't we have a forensic audit of
every election i mean why does it have
to and why why don't we all agree on the
rules ahead of time no matter what
happens and just say after this election
is complete the this is the way in which
it can be investigated so that both
sides feel satisfied in 2016 they were
claiming that russia and russians hacked
voting machines sheamus brought that up
so so
i don't know of any specific uh media
conglomerate that said that that was the
case but they were thrilled to be
misunderstood as saying that every time
they said the phrase russian election
interference or russian interference
there are people who genuinely believe
believe that they were 50 of democrats
believed that russia literally hacked
our voting machines and they repeatedly
said that trump was illegitimate and all
that stuff and that was all allowed and
they spent tens of millions of dollars
investigating this nonsense then when
trump comes out and says something like
it's a big lie and i'm like dude so was
yours if you want unity in this country
then how about we have the the the
dominion probe like the mueller probe or
whatever but they won't do that it's a
double standard and this is what's
gutting the country and tearing it apart
is that if you have all of these hillary
voters who are freaking out and
screaming they got their probe it jammed
up trump for two years
then trump comes out he's angry his
supporters are all angry and they say
nah we're not going to return the favor
well that's how you you shred this
country in half thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time